merci,
c'est dur,
c'est très dur, c'est éprouvant pour les garçons
et les filles, c'est éprouvant pour les membres du personnel,
cela les affecte.
Je pense que nous n'avions pas bu d'eau
depuis environ
12 ans, comme si nous avions littéralement toujours
acheté notre eau,
alors vous prenez toujours une chance.  quand vous vous
baignez dedans
et que vous devez quand même consommer beaucoup
d'
eau en bouteille et faire bouillir vos aliments
parce que vous ne savez pas ce que l'eau est
vraiment contaminée
[Musique]
ce n'est pas comme ça que vous êtes censé construire,
vous savez que ce n'est pas normal  ce n'est pas
normal du tout parce que
combien de temps encore nous devrons acheter de l'
eau
[Musique]
nous avons la boîte à eau ici pour
produire de l'eau propre et nous savons que vous savez, je
dis parce que tout le monde ne peut pas
aller au magasin et acheter de l'eau  tu sais ce que
je dis
mais on donne à l'identité une cruche réutilisable,
[ __ ], amène-la ici et fais le
plein tu sais ce que je dis oh
[Musique]
toi